continuing with what we had begun last
last week with regards to
dealing with the decree of allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
it's a subject that we all need to take
into perspective
and need to spend
much time can contemplating
because the decree of allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
is one of the six pillars of iman
the six pillars of faith
and also in the narration of abdullah
[Silence]
o muhammad tell me about iman and he
came to him in the form of a man
with extremely black hair and very white
clothing who was not from the village
nor was he a traveler
narration that we many of us are
familiar with
and so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam responded
[Silence]
here
he said iman is to believe
in allah to believe
in the books
the angels the books of allah
to believe in the messengers and
prophets of allah
to believe in the last day which is the
day of resurrection
he then repeated the
he said and also that you believe in the
decree of allah
both good and bad of it
so this informs us this articulates to
us
that belief in decree is not only
something which is an
article of faith and a pillar of faith
and iman
and belief but it's also something that
is
crucial for an individual to believe in
and to try to understand now there are
aspects of decree that we will never
understand
because we are human beings and we have
limitations just there are
aspects of the day of resurrection that
we will never understand
there are aspects of the angels that we
will never
understand etc what kind of aspects are
we speaking about well
if i told you there is a place where a
person will burn
forever and ever and ever and ever and
ever
and it will never end it will always get
worse and worse and worse and worse
and every time a person's skin and
tendons are burned away
they are replenished only to be burned
and singed again
this is something that we understand the
meaning of but we can't really
comprehend what that means
because we we have no equivalent of it
in our physical world
to be able to to contrast it with
the same goes with paradise
if i told you that there is a place
where no matter how much a person eats
they will never gain any weight and
every time they eat it tastes better
than the time they ate before
and every time they take a fruit off of
a tree
another fruit that looks exactly it
will reappear but will taste
different what does that mean
i mean we understand the meaning of it
but we don't
we don't really comprehend what that
exactly
understand what that means not until we
experience it that's the only way
and when it comes to the decree of allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala some of the taber in
excuse me some of the taberean
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam of the companions
they had they had said
that decree there is an element of it
that is the secret
of allah it's something that is reserved
only for allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
to completely understand
if we look at something the soul
the human soul
every one of us has a soul
what is the difference between the body
before the soul is put into it and after
the soul is taken out of it
or after the soul is put into it
the body is all the same the actual
tendons and blood and organs and
everything are functioning exactly the
same
what is this soul that if it is present
if there is life and if it is
absent there is decay we have no idea we
don't know
and they ask you about the soul say the
soul is from the soul issues and affairs
of my lord
allah we don't understand really what
that is
how it works we don't understand
what it is about the soul that gives
the body life and what it is about its
absence
that gives about its absence that gives
the body decay
we don't know and that's something that
we all have
that's something that i have and you
have and everyone who is alive has a
soul
yet even though we all have a soul we do
not understand it
we do not know what it is we don't know
what it looks like
and we don't know how it functions
and you know popular culture teaches us
all kinds of
things about the soul we see this a lot
in
in movies and so forth you know
when a person dies his soul comes out of
his body and he starts walking around
he starts floating through walls and you
know
discussing things with other people and
moving things around
and a person may see a ghost or some
kind of
jinn in a building and say well
you know 50 years ago someone died here
and the soul is still
dwelling around as if the soul has
nothing better to do than to just
walk around in this hotel or in this
building all
all of eternity these things are all
stipulation they are all presuppositions
that the soul has some kind of abilities
that we don't understand
the soul is not this when we look
to the sun of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
we see that the soul needs someone to
put it
into the body it needs someone to take
it out of the body
it needs someone to transport it to
allah it needs someone to transport it
to the year after
where is this idea that souls are
roaming around and
walking through walls and so forth and
so
the important part and the important
point that we are taking from all of
this
is that the decree of allah is something
that is part of our faith
we have to believe in it and we have to
try to understand as much of it as we
can
but in trying to understand the decree
of allah
we have to also acknowledge our
limitations
as human beings and that's why allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala begins the first
the first description
of the people of paradise
the first description of the people who
will be saved from
fire the first people
that allah mentions in the quran
that will be spared from the hellfire
and protected what is their first
description he says
the ones who believe in the unseen
those who believe in the unseen those
things which are
unseen un unrecognized by the human
being
senses something things that are super
irrational
we have things that are rational we have
things that are super irrational that
are above our understanding
that we will never understand if i told
you that allah wa ta'ala has no
beginning
and he has no end and he has always been
exactly perfect
and has never gained any one thing from
his creation
what does that mean to us this is
something this is super
super irrational this is above our level
of
comprehension as human beings we know
what the meanings are but we don't know
what
the reality is and this is what the
scholars refer to
the scholars of islam they tell us that
this is the difference between
meanings and
descriptions and the actual the actual
being of something that we may
understand the meaning but we may not
understand what the actual being is what
it actually is
and the names and attributes of allah
are a perfect example of that we
understand
what al qaeda means
we understand what it means when allah
says
and then
he then this articulates time to us
he then rose above his throne
what does that mean exactly rose above
his throne
well we understand what that means in
our language
but we don't understand how he did that
subhana
how do we understand that right
[Silence]
and so when we say allah rose above his
throne we say
he rose above his throne in a way
which is in accordance
and in a way which is
appropriate to his majesty subhanahu
wata'ala
we understand the meaning of rose above
his throne but we do not understand
how he rose above his throne this is a
question that does not
that does not deserve to be asked with
regards to allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
because it's not something that we are
able to comprehend it is beyond our
comprehension
it is something which is supra rational
and this is and this is an important
important
important principle of islam
that if you want to be taken by islam to
the furthest
if you want the quran to take your heart
and turn it into the purest of gold
you have to have faith what does that
faith mean
it means take me where you will even if
i don't understand what it is
and this is one of the reasons why we
have failed
in our recent years as an ummah
is because one of our conditions is that
i have to understand
everything but we don't practice that in
the real world
i mean how many of us really knows how a
car works
a vehicle how it works how many of us
really know
how it works i mean we have some
vague idea maybe some of us
who are more mechanically inclined but
we don't we don't really know
how it works but we believe in it don't
we
and we use it and when we get into it
and we turn the key we have faith that
it's going to turn
on we drive it around and we rely on it
and we drive
thousands of miles and travel right
and this is what allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala tells us he says
they believe in that which is unseen
that which is beyond their comprehension
that which is beyond their senses they
believe in the angels
angels a creation of light they are
neither male
nor are they female what would what what
does that mean
exactly well we don't have to know what
that means
in order to benefit from the book of
allah subhana wa
and so those who are constantly looking
for
explanation usually are ones who
are of weaker and lesser faith
than those who merely believe and
proceed
this is something that's important for
us to understand
now a question arises
what is that question even a scholar
even a genius scholar even a scholar who
has been given at hikma
because you know scholars are human
beings
and they are on different levels there
are
people who are considered scholars and
then there are people who are considered
you know higher level scholars
to the point that they are imams
of their era and there are people that
are scholars of the entire
ummah correct
now does every single scholar understand
every single thing about the quran no
not necessarily there are aspects that
may be beyond
that scholars understanding no matter
how intelligent or knowledgeable he may
be
this doesn't mean that there are parts
of the quran we don't understand
as an ummah as a whole
all of us together all of our scholars
together
collectively yes we understand the
entire quran
but it doesn't mean that every single
person understands every single thing in
the quran
there are parts of it that are a mystery
to some
right and so allah speaks about this in
surat ali imran
[Silence]
he says subhanahu ta'ala and those who
are most
firmly grounded in iman and
understanding
those who are most firmly grounded in
knowledge when they are faced with
something of the revelation of allah
that they do not
understand their response to it is what
we believe in it all of it is from allah
i'm not sure exactly what this verse
means
i'm not sure exactly what this thing
but i believe in it because i know who
it came from that's it
allah referred to this kind of attitude
as what
these are the people who are most
grounded in knowledge
and as for the individual who has the
attitude that he can understand
everything
has the attitude that the quran is under
his thumb
and that he can understand it as soon as
he reads it
and if he can't understand it that no
one can
this individual will go through a lot of
suffering in his life
and this is not just for the quran but
this is also for the actions of allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
when we speak about decree
when we speak about
al-qaeda we are speaking about the
actions of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
that's what we are essentially speaking
about
that you believe in the decree of allah
the predestination of allah the
destiny that allah has written out
the good of it and the bad of it you
have to believe in it that it's from
allah
you have to believe in its existence
and you have to
you have to accept it
and part of the decree of allah is
understanding the human being's free
will
right the fact that i can do
something and i have the choice to move
this or
not move it yet the fact that i did move
it
is part of allah's decree that is what
we're speaking about
and that is something that many many
many people have gone astray
and misunderstood
why have they misunderstood it because
they were unable to understand
the harmonization
the harmony they were unable to
understand
the harmony between the free will
of the human being to do what he chooses
and the decree of allah and the destiny
that allah has written for the human
being
and this is what we were speaking about
last week
we're going to continue that topic
tonight
and we are going to finish it inshaallah
and then we will continue next week
inshaallah with zad al-mahd
of course a small announcement to those
who are present and those who are with
us on the live stream
that you will you will have noticed that
we started
half an hour later than usual and that
time will probably change again
because right now we had a shift in the
daylight saving time
and the days are now becoming longer and
longer
also our normal schedule will be
disrupted by the month of ramadan
because
obviously in ramadan different things
are done
so watch out for all of those
announcements and keep those things in
mind insha'allah
we started today at 7 30 i believe we
started at 7 31 or something
and that may be subject to change even
as soon as next week we're not sure
so just make sure that you follow us on
facebook and you know all these other
places that we
announce these things in order that you
can continue to be updated
last week we spoke about in order for an
individual to
understand the decree of allah and to
properly believe in the decree of allah
they must they must believe in
four things okay so
al-qaeda the decree of allah
when we look through the quran we look
through the sunnah
we see that the qatar has four stages to
it
four levels four things that occur in
order for something to become
part of allah's decree okay
the first is the eternal
knowledge of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
the eternal knowledge of allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
and allah subhanahu wa ta'ala khanna
[Silence]
with the first level what is the first
level
the first level is belief in the
knowledge of allah
the perfect knowledge
of
the perfect level of the perfect
knowledge of allah what does that mean
means that allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
knows
all that was and all that is to be
and all that is and all that would have
been
had things been subhanahu italy
and that this knowledge of his is
intrinsic
it is something which is inherently a
part of allah
it is not something that adds with time
nor is it something which depletes
it's not something that he earns from
outside of himself
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has always
known
and will always know and this is one of
the intrinsic
attributes of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
and this is why this is one of his names
the most knowledgeable the one who knows
all things
the one who knows all
this knowledge of allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala is not something
which which is increased
or depleted ever
what did musa describe allah's
knowledge as when firaoun asked him
foreign when firaoun asked him you claim
you're a prophet
and you claim that people are supposed
to be worshipping allah alone
this is what pharaoh is telling musa
then what about all the other
past generations
musa saddam did not judge the past
generations
he did not say they're all going to hell
and he did not say they're all excused
rather he said their knowledge lies with
my lord which is documented in a book
a book meaning elohim
the preserved tablet of allah
then he described allah's knowledge and
said
my lord is neither unaware nor
does he forget
these are the two things that plague the
human being's knowledge
correct so for example myself
if i have a piece of knowledge before
that
i was ignorant of it correct
and after that i am prone to forget that
piece of knowledge
right so my knowledge is incomplete
in three ways it's incomplete
in its beginning because it started with
ignorance
it's incomplete in its end because it's
followed by forgetfulness
and confusion and it's incomplete
in itself because i don't know something
absolutely one completely
nobody does no human being completely
absolutely something
right and so this is the
the key difference between the knowledge
of allah and the knowledge of the human
being
the knowledge of the human being starts
with ignorance
is preceded by ignorance is followed
by forgetfulness and is plagued with
confusion and imperfection
whilst the knowledge of allah
it has no beginning
it was not preceded by ignorance he
always knew
and it is not followed by ignorance or
forgetfulness or
or confusion and the knowledge of allah
in itself
is perfect and absolute
that he knows everything there is to
possibly know
about every single thing
and he even has perfect knowledge of
those things that don't exist
had they existed
meaning if i were not born me ali if i
were not born
what would the ramifications have been
what smiles would not have been there
what tears would not have been shed what
people
there would have been an effect correct
allah knows that as well
and take that to every single thing that
exists
this is the knowledge of allah that we
are
my throat is very raspy tonight i
apologize for that
say i blame it on the chicago weather
it's you don't know what to do you
know if you
you don't know if you should wear shorts
or wear a jacket you know you
you wake up wearing shorts and you go to
sleep wearing a jacket so i don't know
when we speak about the knowledge of
allah
the first stage and level
of understanding the decree of allah
that is the first level the first level
is the knowledge of allah
subhanahu
what is the second level when it comes
to understanding
the decree of allah now when we say
understanding the decree of allah
it's the same thing that when we say
tafsir or
understanding the quran it's the words
of allah
we understand it as much as humanly
possible
as much as it is possible for a human
being to understand the words of god
that doesn't mean that it's perfect
doesn't mean that we are
but these are what the scholars of islam
have mentioned
that are absolute
levels and stages of belief in allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala's decree
and so the second
stage level
when it comes to the decree of allah
subhanahu ta'ala
belief in allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's
it is what the scholars refer to as
el-kitab
al-kitab what is al-kitab
it is writing what allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has written
what do we mean by written
we don't mean it in a metaphorical sense
we mean it in a literal sense
that this glass of water right here was
written by allah
just as it was known to be
the amount that is in it every movement
of
every molecule inside of it was also
written by allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
where was it written
in the preserved tablet allah mentions
throughout the quran we mentioned it in
the
verse
of
[Silence]
and with him lies the mother and
reference of all the book of decree
right it's mentioned throughout the
quran
this is called the level of writing
what does that mean the level of writing
it means that allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
documented and wrote not
he wrote subhana ta'ala everything that
would come to pass
with regards to this creation here us
every thought that you have every hair
that grows
every movement of a blood cell every
time your heart makes a beat
every thought that passes through your
mind
every piece of pain every signal that
your nerves will give
all of this has been written by allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
now the narration for this is a
narration collected by imam
ahmed rahimahullah
[Silence]
m
foreign
so in this narration of imam ahmed some
individuals
came to the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
from yemen and they said we came to ask
you about the
beginnings of this universe this
creation here
and he said at the very beginning
there was a law and there was nothing
else and he created the pen
and he said to the pen right
and the pen said what shall i write
allah then said to the pen write all
that is to be
until the day of resurrection
now where did the pen get this knowledge
from
from allah from the first level of
decree we just spoke about he said
and from that moment on the pen
continued to write
all that is to be and that was 50
000 years before the first creation of
the heavens and the earth
fifty thousand years what kind of years
were those
are they our years fifty thousand of our
years
[Arabic recitation]
it's a difference of opinion amongst the
scholars
[Silence]
and so 50 000 years we don't know
what that really means because it's a
difference of opinion amongst the
scholars
is it years how we count years or
years the years of allah we don't
know
in naomi
he said a day with your lord is is
equivalent to a thousand
of your years that you count and
calculate so we don't know
but the point is is that this is the
level of writing
right now this
writing has it stopped did it reach a
point where it ended
no it's continuing till now right
in the narration of abimus
muslim when the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam ascended
when the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam ascended to the seventh heaven
and he met with ibrahim alaihissalam
and then he reached a point where jibril
said
i cannot go past this point you have to
go alone now
and so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
entered and he said that he was close
enough to see
he said and i was brought so close to
allah
that i heard the scratching of the pens
on the tablets what is that scratching
of the pens on the tablets
those are the pens of decree they are
they're continuing till today when he
went to meet allah those pens were still
riding
and they will continue to write for
eternity
because paradise has no end correct
and everything that's going to happen in
paradise is going to continue to happen
and everything that happens in the hell
fire is going to continue to happen
right therefore there are eight things
that the scholars of islam have gathered
from all of the quran and sunnah
and they said these eight things
have a beginning
[Silence]
he says there are eight things that have
a beginning
and they have no end what are these
eight things
the scholars say the human soul
has a beginning it has no end
the second thing is
the tailbone of the human being
remember the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam told us that the tailbone is
what the human being will be
reconstructed by
and rasulullah
[Silence]
home
the third thing that has a beginning and
has no end
set up
oops it's falling apart i should have
told you about that
okay let me hold it here and you set
this
set it in there
there we go thank you very much
and so there are eight things which have
a beginning and have no end
number one we said is the human soul
number two odds with venom is the
tailbone
the absolute last vertebrae on the spine
of the human being
the tailbone it's also referred to
clinically as the coccyx
right this is this is what will not have
this will
the earth does not deplete this
the third thing is the pen
the pen that writes the decree
the fourth thing is the is the tablet
that the pen writes on that has no end
either
likewise is the hellfire is the sixth
thing
which will continue for eternity
the seventh thing is the throne of allah
subhanahu
taught us how to ask allah
he taught us an important difference
between us
and allah
he said if you all ask allah for
paradise ask him for the highest level
because the highest level its ceiling is
allah's throne
subhanahu wa
some people they ask allah as if they're
asking a human being
[Silence]
how do we ask allah some people say
i don't care how i get to paradise insha
allah i crawl into the lowest level of
paradise i just want to go
yani is
for this reason he said if you ask
allah ask him for the highest level of
paradise
is it because you deserve the highest
level of paradise
do i deserve the highest level of
paradise absolutely not
it is because allah
is the most generous subhanna with
and it is most befitting of allah to
give the greatest
even to those who don't deserve it
subhanahu
and the final and eighth thing
that has a beginning and has no end is
the footstool
al-kursiy right
[Silence]
has encompassed the heavens and the
earth
now what is alcorti
in the arabic language is a footstool
that is the eighth thing that has a
beginning and has no end allah created
it
as he created the throne but it will
never ever end it all will always be in
existence
after its creation
and so
the second level of
or the second stage
of belief in the decree of allah
is belief in the writing
of what allah subhanahu wa ta'ala knows
will come to be so the first level
and now
now we need to take a moment here before
we end
i thought we would be able to finish
tonight but we will not we'll continue
next week insha'allah
and that is that aloha
literally translates to the preserved
tablet the preserved
book of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
does it change
is it something that is subject to
change
allah wrote 50 000 years before the
creation
this would occur but later will it be
erased and rewritten
to something else
refer to it as the preserved tablet
what's the point of calling it preserved
if it's not preserved
if it's constantly changing
foreign
[Silence]
and before we end i'll mention a
narration that's
going around allah
[Silence]
there's a narration that's floating
around that
it's kind of late inshallah next week we
will mention this narration
so you will tune in next week we'll
mention this narration it's time for
that now
foreign